a little bit slow uh in the last few
weeks going into the shutdown
speaking of confidence how about that
that started with a breakup of a pass
perez
during the game after lebron dunt he
either
said i'm still the baddest out here or
i'm still the fastest out here
[Music]
okay i asked lebron if he said that he
was still the baddest or still the
fastest
he looked at me and said what do you
think i said
welcome to orlando the local time is 10
33
most importantly always have to start
the day with the mask
[Music]
on the way to practice number one
okay so right now we are in the wild
water sports on the northwest side
getting ready to go to rockets practice
it's the first practice that we are
going to
teams or staggered throughout the city
in different locations but rockets are
right now
thank you austin good job jersey
background we got to practice
one question heading
to practice number two going to watch
the miami heat
thomas oh yes mickey time
[Music]
hold on don't get me right now my man's
not up where are we going
how are you chad i'm fantastic so you
said that it was going to be
tvd um what you do with your jersey
what was the feeling when it was
rejected uh
i mean you can't say that i didn't think
that it would
be a problem but like i said i'm hoping
that they come back and see the message
that i want
to get out there and let me speak on
something the way that i would like to
speak on
like i said to the term we really don't
know i'll keep pressing for it
and i hear uh plenty of other players
around the league would like to do the
same
so i just um i hope that they see the
message that we want to get across
they let us be who we are
i brought
[Music]
okay tuesday july 21st very busy day
we're headed to blazers practice first
[Music]
portland wins the award for best dj best
[Music]
lakers practice second
[Music]
so we know obviously you're focused on
winning but we heard vogel talk about
why you should be defensive player of
the year uh what were your thoughts on
what he said and what's
every um you know my biggest impact that
i think i have with defensively i love
playing defense
um i love stopping other players
end the um with the celtics practice
[Music]
there we go man
i am exhausted uh best parts of today
the lakers
ended their pre-practice huddle putting
hands in and saying
one two three mamba um
there was a really nice really really
touching moment
that was my favorite part of the day i
think i'm going to end on that first day
of
actual basketball play because
it's a competition teams facing one
another i'm looking forward to it so
i'm headed to the arena right now
[Music]
that was different you know when you
come out for once and like literally
no one is out there and i went over
to some of the referees um talked to
leon
and scott a little bit beforehand and
even then they were like this is just
surreal
all right it's thursday july 23rd i'm
getting ready as you can see
very big day second day of scrimmages
i'll be at bucks spurs at three
then i'll be at lakers maps at seven
okay
[Music]
so once these scrimmages are over what
will success look like for you meaning
what will you have to see to say okay we
got better these serve their purpose
well we got to get better on the
defensive side of the ball it's been a
struggle for us all year
we've been poor in transition and we've
been poor uh
in the half court defense we've got to
get better rim protection i mean you
could go down the list
there's a litany of things that we can
do better defensively
and i think that's that's the big growth
piece
the cleaning crew we've washed our hands
there's a door we can't touch it
it's the beginning get the beginning
victory
so if you can hear ether my nas is
playing right now
matisse bible goes is this joe budden
your map perfectly fits at your beard
yeah
there we go there we go adidas adidas
actually right gang
hello
[Music]
we're so gonna miss the bus sitting here
vlogging talking to you guys